it's a little bit harder to unwind the
kind of progressive identity politics
that has come to define the left which
is also a threat to liberalism because a
lot of it becomes very intolerant and
well it isn't liberal I would argue it
isn't liberal and it also denies a
fundamental premise about you know the
universal equality of human beings
because it says well actually you know
it used to be that the white
supremacists would say that white people
are superior and now you know the shoot
gets on the other foot and it says that
marginalized communities are the ones
that ought to be given advantages and I
think neither of those is compatible
with you know with true liberalism